Oh back we come alright what's up
everyone welcome to simulation we are
gonna be talking about our thoughts on
the Georgia Guidestones
so you might be wondering what the [ __ ]
are the Georgia Guidestones well I'll
tell you this they're actually pretty
important thought there are pretty
important landmark and they really
stimulate some interesting thoughts so
let's take a dive into the Wikipedia
article on Georgia Guidestones together
so the first thing that when we look at
it we see a granite monument erected in
1980 in Georgia in the US so there's a
set of ten guidelines and scribed on in
eight modern languages okay
so we're talking about 19 feet three
inches tall so this is kind of what it
looks like right here
so these massive 19 foot slabs have
these ten in Georgia have these ten
rules and scribed on them and so Georgia
is right here you know on the map and
there's right there in the US and so
alright now what the what the hell are
these ten things and like what was the
purpose of writing them so here are the
inscriptions they're written in English
Spanish Swahili Sanskrit Hebrew Arabic
Chinese and Russian and I'm gonna break
these down for you I'm going to tell you
kind of what I think about each one of
them as we go okay so maintaining
humanity under 500 million in perpetual
balance of nature okay why is that there
well okay we have seven and a half
billion people right now and that's
quite a bit of people and maybe it's
easier for us to perpetually be with
nature at about 500 million now the
question is we're not gonna go and start
murdering people but the idea is
actually over time population will
likely decline more and more
advancements will be made to parents mom
and dad will probably only have one kid
each one kid together so from two people
down to one so the replacement fertility
rate isn't gonna keep up you're not
gonna have two kids with two parents
there's gonna be one parent what two
parents one kid so eventually population
has been declining in these developed
areas of the world the only areas of the
world where it's not declining are
places like Africa where in many cases
the population is still increasing
because it's still developing people are
still having about six kids or so
so actually over time it might
organically happen that our population
declines to about there
now it's not that difficult to actually
get there over time either there's
others of course there's other ways to
get there as well the idea of oh well
why don't we only let the smartest of us
breed how do we measure the smartest of
us maybe that would be a good idea that
actually leads us right into the second
point which is guide reproduction wisely
improving fitness and diversity okay
hypothetically if you guided
reproduction wisely what if I didn't get
to reproduce cuz I wasn't smart enough
okay great
maybe it's better for civilization that
only the smartest however we measure
that reproduce maybe me maybe you and
eight other people seven other people
including you and I don't get to
reproduce but then the tenth person gets
to reproduce because they're smarter
than us across some sort of measurement
scale and that's guiding reproduction
wisely maybe it's for physical traits
maybe it's for people that are very
physically attractive maybe it's for
people that are very physically strong
that I'm strong metabolism a strong
working memory
what are these ways that we can improve
fitness and diversity meanwhile also
potentially keeping a perpetual balance
of nature and maintaining humanity under
a certain population threshold because
we do sway out of the Thresh we do sway
out of perpetual balance of nature when
we have so many people and when those so
many people are doing things like
consuming so damn much burning so many
fossil fuels all those things and we are
contributing to that as well so maybe
this is important talk about three Third
Point unite humanity with the living new
language okay I just also want to make
sure that we're looking at who did this
and this is 1979 someone named Robert C
Christian he did this on behalf of a
small oil group of Americans and um they
commissioned the structure has accepted
the quote and they did it and then you
know they've been them they've been
defaced over time and stuff and some
people call it one of the most brilliant
things some people call it one of the
most hated things so it's very
interesting the difference between
but it's also interesting that somebody
paid to Commission this into our world
okay the next point unite humanity with
living new language we talk about this
all the time like what the hell is this
right now I'm vibrating vocal cords
you're listening somehow it's making
sense in your brain
we're lucky we made language but what's
better than language will we even be
using our vocal cords anymore am I just
gonna think and telepathically
communicate to you what are these brain
computer interfaces gonna look like but
also maybe we don't even need to think
maybe there's just a feeling of some
sort that for communication what is this
new living language how can we make it
so all seven and a half billion people
can communicate effectively with each
other right now there's those really
great translation devices where I can
speak in English and one side and on the
other side will come out and Mandarin so
interesting in real-time so we're
already a lot of people are studying
language and stuff I keep telling people
don't study language I think language is
really important to expand your mind to
new dimensions of thinking and to
increase creamy matter all these cool
things that people think are you know
really happening and that are really
important and I think they are to making
people more intelligent but at the same
time we're going away from the need to
know so many different languages with
these instantaneous translation device
so what is a new language rule for rule
passion faith tradition all things with
tempered reason seems to be something
that keeps some of the tradition from
humanity have some faith and where
humanism is going rule with passion and
all these things with tempered reason
seems pretty good rule 5 protect people
in nations with fair laws in just courts
this is tough cuz we need to know what a
fair law is and what a just court is but
in general those are good concepts right
so a fair law maybe something like thou
shalt not kill like don't kill people
ok great nobody will kill you I won't
kill people ok good but if somebody does
kill then they go to court the in prison
maybe there's rehabilitation whatever it
may be ok let all nations rule
internally resolving external disputes
in a World Court okay so all these
nations will rule internally and then
anything
happens as an external dispute will
happen in the world Court again seems
like a pretty good rule that if the US
has an issue domestically that will take
care of it domestically and then if
something happens between the u.s. and
Canada then we need to bring it to world
court where more people are involved in
talking about how that process will
happen is really difficult to know but
these are kind of interesting governing
principles ok7 avoid petty laws and
useless officials definitely there's a
shitload of petty laws and useless
officials that are all over and that's
why there's this thick in this thick
layer of goop that's baked on top of the
US government right now which is the
incumbency all of this money that is
corrupt and and so having these useless
officials that are some of them did
study poli-sci or law how many of them
studied science or engineering how many
of them studied you know ethics and
philosophy right we need more people
like this in positions of power as well
in our governing system more women more
people of color people that represent
the United States population and as well
as you know the world population in that
sense as well and petty loss yeah let's
get rid of like jaywalking and and and
tickets for four parking meters and
things like that let's figure out how to
advance past the silly things like that
with these petty laws okay
all the crazy have you ever seen a San
Francisco street sign
no parking two a.m. to 6:00 a.m. Monday
through Friday on Tuesday and Wednesday
their street cleaning from 12 a.m. to 2
a.m. don't park your car there then also
no parking your car upside down or left
side right or up to down the hill like
there's too many stupid petty
regulations that are going on we got to
figure out how to become better at that
ok balance personal rights with social
duties this is crucial you got to take
on some damn responsibility in your life
you know Jordan Peterson talks about
this all the time get some damn
responsibility on your shoulders and go
forth and bring it to the world so
people typically scream I want my rights
I want my rights I want my rights ok
great
but you have to have some sort of a
social duty you have to have a
responsibility as well in order to get
these rights so you're not just born
into
world and you're automatically given
everything you've ever imagined that
will well maybe you should also have a
mentality if I want to bring something
of value to the world and receive these
rights at the same time price truth
beauty love seeking harmony with the
infinite interesting what a seeking
harmony with the infinite mean does that
mean the infinity of my divinity of my
being the infinity of the infinity of
the universe and the universes of the
cosmic perspective what is this divinity
in this infinity that we're talking
about because seeking harmony with it
becoming a pinnacle civilization is
something that I strive for so much and
I find that interesting prising truth
beauty and love all very important to me
as well it's very interesting k10 be not
a cancer on earth leave room for nature
leave room for nature the fact that they
had to repeat twice leave room for
nature leave room for nature is a sign
that we're not leaving room for nature
right now take a look at our metropolis
everybody's moving into metropolis it's
not everybody but a vast amount of
people are moving into metropolis and
the metropolis is are suffocated
suffocated you go out here on Market
Street
there's no [ __ ] trees there's no
[ __ ] parks there's no animals rolling
around there's some there's some pigeons
these rats with wings all over the damn
brick pass that are getting human hair
caught in their feet and then they're
freaking getting infections and dying
right there
and this is like that's us not leaving
room for nature we didn't build the city
with the intention to have these amazing
parks and open spaces and greeneries and
ecosystems
we're not leaving nature we're just
throwing slabs of concrete everywhere
and it's getting quite annoying thinking
about how we're building metropolis the
Singapore has done a pretty good job at
incorporating our ecology which is
blending together ecology with
architecture our ecology into their
ecosystem and then be not a cancer on
earth seriously the earth will shake us
off like a bad case of fleas that is
what ron vargas the producing partner
the show talks about a lot and just know
that that is very much so the potential
case for what could happen is if humans
don't figure out how to get along and
mend with me
there could be a serious extinction
again and how many times has happened
before so this is actually pretty
interesting
interestingly enough the Georgia
Guidestones these 20-foot tall slabs in
Georgia that were erected a couple
decades ago that are now standing with
these somewhat interestingly wise I
think a lot of these things are wise why
would we not want to leave room for
nature why would we not want to price
truth and seek harmony with the infinite
these are very interesting things that I
think many people can actually agree on
now probably a lot of people disagree
with 500 million people how are we gonna
get there all this stuff but they also
wrote it in a bunch of different
languages which is interesting so this
has been our thoughts on the Georgia
Guidestones
most of you probably haven't heard about
the Georgia Guidestones Ron taught me
about the Georgia Guidestones it's
really important for you to go and share
this with two people go share Georgia
Guidestones have them go share it have
more conversations about this get some
more awesome thought-provoking
conversation going on around the world
about this and send us a comment below
let us know your thoughts about the
Georgia Guidestones
will continue making these awesome
thoughts on videos thanks for joining us
our thoughts on the Georgia Guidestones
much love